[Music]
good morning folks
i just decided that i want to do another
what i eat in a day video i thought
about the one i did two years ago
and a lot has changed not only in my
routine but also in my youtube videos
that one was just so
cringy energy to be utilized throughout
the day
so i'm gonna take you through what i eat
for breakfast lunch dinner and
everything in between
with the help of my partner life sum
who's gonna help me track
my calories macronutrients
micronutrients all that good stuff
are you ready to come along for the ride
give me five oh you missed it one more
time
no this hand this one give me five yeah
my breakfast has changed a little bit
since my last video
so let me show you what i eat for
breakfast nowadays this is my breakfast
lately i haven't been eating breakfast
i've become a huge fan of intermittent
fasting
where i have 14 to 16 hours since my
last meal like right now i'm about to go
on national television i have to be
super sharp talk about
cbd it's kind of interesting if you guys
want to hear more about cbd drop it down
below in the comments i'm going to go on
tv without eating anything i feel
sharper
i feel more engaged and this is
consistent with some of the leading
research
that's showing intermittent fasting can
be a good idea now it's not right for
everybody and i don't recommend you
start without chatting with a doctor
first but it certainly works for me i
need a little caffeine kick but i'm not
a huge fan of overdoing it
i drink my magic sauce and that's green
tea
[Music]
ignition sequence star six
five four three two
one zero all engine running
now my fresh cup of tea is ready to go
as i told you in my hot tea video
you don't want to drink anything that's
above 140 degrees fahrenheit
so i do let it chill for a little bit
before i take a sip gives me a nice
little boost with a tiny bit of caffeine
instead of that caffeine kick that i get
if i'm drinking a cup of coffee
i need that sometimes but not most
mornings especially when i'm going on
television i don't want to look crazy
[Music]
all right i got this yummy bowl steak
sweet potatoes broccoli
over here i got my avocado toast with
some sriracha flakes this bowl
is a go-to bowl for me it has protein
has complex carbohydrates
antioxidants from the broccoli and on
top of it it has a romesco sauce
olive oil healthy fats you know they say
you are what you eat
i guess i must be nutritious i'm gonna
pull up my lifestyle map here and enter
what i ate
multi grain if i can spell
toast guacamole single potato
steak grass-fed so for lunch i've
already had
773 calories which is really close to my
800 gold the only thing is my sodium is
quite high
that's because i'm eating out there's a
lot of sauces there's a lot of sodium in
there i'm going to cut myself a break on
this one meal and go 200 milligrams over
so you may have noticed bears wearing
his
in training jacket the biggest reason he
needs that jacket
is just so inconsiderate dog owners
don't let their dogs just run up to him
because some people think that all dogs
should just be playing while they're on
leash
that is not the case dogs need to
respect other dogs space
and that's part of teaching your dog
proper etiquette that's how you train a
pup
now a lot of you may not know this but
i'm pretty good at basketball rain dance
making a rain dr j
[Music]
i told you before that i like doing all
different types of activities to stay
fit
basketball is one of them if i can't
find a game i'm just going to go ahead
and just dribble by myself
you know i can play one-on-one on
one-on-one which is with my imaginary
cell
banks open on tuesdays folks it's snack
time all right i'm about to grab my
favorite post-workout snack it may
surprise you not a huge fan of
post-workout cheeks because they make me
feel bloated so i get some
berries and mango mmm this is like
really good
fiber sugars to get that insulin kick
after you work
out and then the magic sauce boom
boiled whole eggs a lot of people don't
like these because they think they're
tasteless
i think they're delicious then because i
need some electrolytes to refuel
i'm gonna get some pink himalayan salt
here dip get a little bit of salt on
there just a pinch
[Music]
a lot of people will say oh i don't like
it without ketchup and mayo look if you
need a dab of ketchup
or a dab of mayo to make a healthy meal
appetizing
make it happen just don't throw in a
whole you know three tablespoons full of
mayo and expect that meal to be still be
healthy
now i go into my favorite part
blueberries
one of the most antioxidant rich berries
out there one of the best fruits to eat
hard boiled egg blueberries
strawberries and then last but not least
mango here's our stats
334 calories 17 grams of protein
31 grams of carbs 16 grams of fat
160 milligrams of sodium now the sodium
might be a little bit higher because i
did
sprinkle a little bit on my eggs but i
think that's pretty negligible at this
point now it's time for me to take a
shower
kick back relax a little bit with bear
maybe a little
netflix and chill if you know what i
mean who netflix and chills with their
dog he loves
to wrestle yeah yeah
can we just collapse her all the time
[Music]
i'm gonna enjoy myself a greek salad
with
grilled chicken greek salad is the way
to go you're getting tomatoes
cucumbers olives all power vegetables
then you got your grilled chicken
clean source of protein a little olive
oil and vinegar just for the
extra little taste kick after a long day
filming
hanging out with bear doing tv this is a
nice thing to come home to and i'm gonna
say this is roughly eight ounces of
chicken a small avocado
half a tomato one ounce of olive oil
there's a little feta in here
feta feta we got 829 calories in this
meal 71 grams of protein
22 carbs 54 grams of fat
all healthy fat sodium 12 16 which is
under what i'm supposed to be eating for
this meal and this is a perfect dinner
for me
at least for my goals for those of you
who have not lived in manhattan
storage comes at a premium so when i get
a lot of groceries
i have to store them in all of all
places
in my dishwasher and i know that's
really funny to say
but i don't use a dishwasher a lot i
order out a lot
and if i'm washing dishes i can just do
them by hand in the dishwa
in a dishwasher not gonna sink but what
i do use it for
is for storing my nuts
[Music]
i love nuts i'm actually not joking i
really do love nuts that's about half a
cup
i feel like you guys are going to be
judging me so hard for using my
dishwasher
look my dishwasher is confused already
it turned on because it's like is it
time
no it's not time there's groceries
inside here don't wash them
healthy fats galore here even a little
bit of protein to finish off my day
what i want you to understand from
watching me today having my final snack
here
this is what i ate today it's not what i
eat every day
that's an important distinction and one
of the most most important distinctions
is that this diet that i follow this
specific eating plan that i follow
is not for everybody now it's what works
for me it's what i'm eating right now
that may change but again nutrition has
to be individualized
it's different from person a from person
b and even person c
i bet you didn't expect i was throwing
person c in there bare likes hang out
with me
why eat nuts because obviously bears
love nuts i actually don't know if
that's a thing
i'm 49 calories over which means that
i'm right in the right spot for calories
i undereat my protein just a little bit
but i overate fats
that's going to happen on a day to day
variance remember this is what i eat in
a day today
now what i eat every day there's going
to be some variation a really simple
takeaway for you
decrease the refined sugars decrease the
processed foods
and increase the fruits and vegetables
and plants in your diet
as well as those proteins because that's
how you stay happy and healthy
and speaking of happy and healthy as
always
do you want to do it as always stay
happy and healthy
coming from bear and check out this
video right little bear pup
you